Google may have just destroyed the
iPhone 14 with the new pixel 7A and
today we're going to compare everything
from the design the speakers the display
the performance and more seems like
Google's finally listening to their
users and they've packed a ton of cool
features into this phone now it costs
500 bucks compared to 800 so that is a
big price difference but I think you
guys will be surprised now right away I
like this size the screens on these are
the same but holding it in the hand it
feels really comfortable let's compare
it to the iPhone that has these flat
edges the iPhone actually feels thicker
compared to this subtle curve as far as
the design you guys let me know which
one you think looks better but I will
say that Google did a great job the
previous pixel a series phones felt kind
of cheap this one feels Ultra Premium I
like how the camera bump is actually
color matched to the color of the phone
and the glass on the back actually
curves into the frame like the upcoming
iPhone 15 Pro now I do think that the
iPhone's camera bump looks better and
with that we're going to be doing
another blind camera comparison with
these two phones and another mystery
phone so make sure you guys click that
subscribe button and turning it on look
at those
those are I thought the fall bigger with
the same size screen and now it makes
sense now the pixel has an under display
fingerprint reader which is really nice
for a budget device and of course the
iPhone has face ID which I think is a
little quicker and I do prefer it now as
far as the detail of the screen they
both look excellent they have a very
similar resolution but the pixel
actually has a 90 Hertz display compared
to 60 hertz on the iPhone so you guys
can see that it is smoother now what I'm
curious about is the brightness because
that's a way where companies can save
some money and look at that difference
the top camera is probably blown out the
iPhone has a way brighter display at
least indoors in the Sun the pixel kicks
up its brightness getting close to the
iPhone so it looks like they are
limiting that for the purpose of battery
life now in terms of HDR video the
iPhone smashes the pixel having much
brighter brights where just pops the
Shadows also have more detail I mean it
looks a lot better but what about the
speakers when you're actually watching
and listening something let's go ahead
and compare them
[Music]
oh
well you guys heard that for yourselves
the iPhone is louder and it sounds
better in every single way so sorry
pixel you cannot compete but what about
performance now the base iPhone for the
first time has six gigs of RAM but the
pixel budget has eight it also has the
same game G2 processor like the 7 Pro
whereas the iPhone has the a15 bionic
let's run the new geekbench 6 and see
how they compare and look at that that
is a massive difference we have a
difference of 63 percent in terms of
single core and a difference of 70 in
terms of multi-core and this is last
year's processor now with that said the
smoothness on the pixel is just fine it
can handle everything but if you're
going to keep it for many years that's
where you will have an issue but what
does make a difference today is gaming
performance so I have 3D Mark open up
right here set to the unlimited mode
that way the resolution is the same and
let's see the difference and look at
that once again we have a difference of
nearly 70 percent so if you're a gamer
the pixel 7A isn't really a good choice
for you now what about the general speed
so let's go ahead and open up the
YouTube app at the same time
loading bam iPhone just slightly faster
not by much and how about web browsing I
have speedometer 2.0 right here and not
only does it test browsing web but
loading up JavaScript and a bunch of
other tasks the iPhone is done it
literally did that in less than half the
time and wow my goodness I was not
expecting that we have 351 runs per
minute compared to
96.4 so the iPhone is more than three
and a half times faster so it is
definitely snappier than the pixel with
that said the pixel does have some cool
software features that you won't get on
the iPhone so Google is definitely
optimizing for the software experience
whereas the iPhone has satellite
connectivity so even if you're in the
middle of nowhere you can have a
connection and be safe in emergency
situations now as far as the battery
life the pixel 7 8 has a battery that's
about 30 percent larger than the iPhone
which is awesome but with that the
display has a 90 Hertz refresh rate and
it is not variable so in the real world
the iPhone will actually do slightly
better and on top of that it's actually
surprising that the iPhone can have
faster charging it will support up to
like 26 Watts whereas the pixel is
limited to 18 watts and the pixel for
the first time has wireless charging
built in but it's capped at 7.5 watts
compared to up to 15 with Max save
charging on the iPhone as for cameras
Google made a big deal about the pixel's
new 64 megapixel sensor compared to 12
on the iPhone and here we have a shot of
Vadim you guys let me know which one
looks better to you guys I'm going to
zoom in right here and to me
surprisingly the iPhone looks like it
has more detail of course it's stacking
with deep Fusion now where I think this
is really going to help is for Zoom shot
so I have a zoom shot right here and and
both of them look terrible Zoom the same
way now I can't actually see the address
right here where here I can't but I
thought that 64 megapixels cropped in
would look a lot better than 12. I am
honestly shocked about this now as I
mentioned we are going to do an unbiased
blind camera comparison where vadima
Angelica are going to choose which one
looks better without knowing which one
is which we're also going to throw in
another surprise phone so make sure you
guys are subscribed for a lot more shots
now for the ultra wide this is the only
camera that is both 12 megapixel the
iPhone looks Moody but if we zoom in
here you can see that the pixels
definitely looks nicer and for our last
shot we have this portrait selfie of me
the pixel looks a little nicer with more
contrast but the background is more
blown out and then looking at the face
the iPhone definitely looks more
detailed so make sure you guys have
notification is enabled for that full
unbiased comparison so with all of that
said does the pixel destroy the iPhone
well I thought it would smoke it but
after looking at everything the iPhone
is clearly the winner in terms of
Hardware the pixel has a couple things
that are better but it wasn't as big a
difference as I expected now with that
said still a great phone this thing
costs 500 bucks compared to 800 and the
build quality in the feel is fantastic
for a phone of this price so you guys
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below click that Circle
above to subscribe and check out one of
those great videos right over there
[Music]
oh